throughout this pandemic time has played
tricks on us
today the office for national statistics
said that last week
there were more than 50 000 new
infections a day
in england and this past means that now
our future is set this is a chart of
deaths in england you'll see it was
almost at a thousand at the peak of the
pandemic
it's currently at 300 a day but
government scientific advice say that
with our current level of cases
deaths are inevitably going to double
over the next two weeks
by mid-november they'll say we'll be at
600
to 700 deaths a day the question
is not all we can do to stop that what
we can do to stop
it doubling again which brings us to
this
nottingham one of the latest cities to
be put into tier three
although just before that happened you
got scenes like this
but although a picture can tell a
thousand words it doesn't
always tell a thousand data points
this is a chart of confirmed cases and
nottingham per capita
you can see it's been falling for some
time
it's the same in liverpool which was the
first city to go into tier three
in fact in liverpool cases were already
falling
when tier three was introduced although
to give the government some credits
they fell more sharply after tft three
came in
the government will see hope in this but
when i ask them
scientific advisors say that isn't the
full picture
because testing isn't picking up a lot
of cases
and crucially cases are growing among
older people
not picking up test confirmed cases with
testing
is just like it was in march and april
and that's why to get a really full
picture of what's going on
you need to think about infections as a
whole
this is a graph of confirmed cases
throughout the pandemic
and this is an estimate
of the total number of infections by
imperial college you'll see
they've got it going over 160 a day at
the peak
right now it's not growing as fast as it
was in march
but look you still see that inexorable
drift upwards if you ask government
scientific advisors
they almost universally tell you that
this
is taking us towards national lockdown